today the Matt wall show Democrats prove
once again that they are the most evil
political party in American history by
voting against legislation that would
guarantee medical treatment to infants
born alive after an abortion they tried
to come up with other reasons to object
to the bill but as we'll see today all
those reasons are absurd also after
another Transportation related
catastrophe there are even more
questions about what exactly Pete
buttige does all day plus a business
owner faces the Pitchfork mob after
video Services of him spraying a
homeless woman with a hose in our daily
cancellation the Golden Globes were
hosted by a gay black man which means
that his performance was automatically
praised as Brave and inspiring but I
have a slightly different take we'll
talk about all that and more today on
the Matt Walsh show
foreign
Heart Association recommends four to
five servings each of fruits and
vegetables every single day that's no
small task especially given my busy
schedule you're probably uh in the same
boat that's why I'm a huge fan of
balance of nature balance of nature
fruits and veggies are the best way to
make sure you're getting essential
nutritional ingredients every single day
their products are 100 Whole Food
ballots of nature uses a cold vacuum
process that preserves the natural
phytonutrients in whole fruits and
veggies and encapsulates them for easy
consumption balance of nature sent a
bunch of their products down to the
office for our team to try and everyone
loves them you got to go to
balanceofnature.com use promo code walls
for 25 off your first order as a
preferred customer plus a free fiber and
spice that's balanceofnature.com promo
code Walsh for 25 off your first
preferred order
welcome to the show this will be my last
show for the next few days as we prepare
to welcome two new children into the
family my wife is scheduled to be
induced tomorrow so at this time
tomorrow we will likely have two
newborns on our hands and many people
you know have asked me how how do we do
it how do we go from four kids to six
kids and manage such a roster expansion
without becoming totally overwhelmed and
the answer is well I don't know but
we'll figure it out like that's the
answer as as is so often the case in
life that is the answer nobody plans on
having a second set of twins or even a
first set so these are decisions made
above our pay grade and all we do is
accept it with gratitude take the rest
day by day I honestly have no idea how
exactly one manages life with six kids
nine under and two infants you know over
the span of the next year
but the good news is that we don't have
to manage it for a year we only have to
manage it for a day and then another day
and another day Etc right and figure the
rest out as we go that's the best advice
I can give to new parents who are
feeling worried or overloaded with new
responsibility and now I'll get another
chance to try and follow my own advice
which is always good now the impending
birth of our fifth and sixth children
was very much on my mind when I read
about the story that we're opening the
show with today actually it's two
stories related and both happening in
the House of Representatives first the
House of Representatives now under GOP
control voted on and passed a resolution
condemning the terrorist attacks on
pro-life pregnancy centers across the
country there are dozens of these
attacks that have happened often
including vandalism arson and they've
been carried out over the past six
months especially since Roe was
overturned um they are they are not only
crimes under state laws state laws that
prohibit things like vandalism and arson
but they're also federal crimes in
violation of the face Act and you may
recall the face act you may have heard
about it recently as it's the federal
law that is that has been wielded
recently against pro-lifers who have
been charged with allegedly getting too
close to the entrance of an abortion
clinic
um one pro-life activist in Pennsylvania
was arrested at his home in the middle
of the night by federal agents because
of this act you violated this act
allegedly
needless to say the groups waging a
terror campaign against pro-life
pregnancy centers even though those
pregnancy centers are covered under the
face act
um and and these terrorists are
blatantly violating that very same law
they have not been pursued with the same
Vigor in fact it doesn't seem like
they're being pursued at all
the resolution condemning the attacks
then is of course symbolic it has no
actual teeth the terrorists are already
breaking the law multiple laws it's not
as though an additional law is needed or
would have any effect anyway but it is
very notable if not surprising that
nearly every Democrat voted against the
measure all but three
219 in total voted no on a resolution
which simply declared that the House of
Representatives is opposed to setting
pregnancy centers on fire that's the
basic gist of the resolution
and they voted no obviously because
they're not opposed to setting pregnancy
centers on fire
now there are a few Democrats who
countered with uh a a different idea you
know they they said well let's have a
resolution that condemns attacks on both
pro-life centers and abortion clinics
they would not condemn the former unless
the latter was also condemned they said
but that compromise would be no good
because for one thing a tax on abortion
clinics have already been sufficiently
condemned by all of the most powerful
institutions and people in the country
we already know that the system condemns
attacks on abortion clinics we we hear
it every day okay anytime the
conversation comes up about abortion
anytime pro-lifers are mentioned we hear
condemnations on these alleged attacks
that are happening
so it's not needed that's already been
happening
we do not know
that these same people actually do
condemn attacks on pro-life centers
actually and now we know that they
explicitly do not condemn them
also when we talk about an attack on a
pro-life Center
we mean that it was vandalized or it was
set on fire
but when the other side talks about
attacks on abortion clinics they include
protesters standing peacefully outside
the building to them that's an attack
this is why conservatives can never join
with leftist condemnations of attacks
because to them any form of opposition
is an attack
yeah this somehow was not the most uh
you know shameful moment the Democrat
Party had yesterday for that here's the
daily wire report in one of its first
acts this this session the GOP
controlled house passed a bill Wednesday
geared toward ensuring steps are taken
by Health Providers to protect infants
born alive after an attempted abortion
the bill called the born alive abortion
survivors protection act establishes
that Healthcare practitioners who do not
reasonably act to preserve the life and
health of the child after an attempted
abortion as they would any newborn face
fines or up to five years imprisonment
the bill also outlines civil remedies
for the mother of an abortion Survivor
this reasonable legislation would
protect a baby born alive following an
abortion said Carol Tobias president of
the national right to life the bill
isn't about interfering with the
so-called right to abortion it's about
stopping infanticide Congress must act
now to pass this legislation and protect
these vulnerable babies
the bill ultimately did pass through the
house anyway but nearly every Democrat
once again voted against it so not only
will they not condemn setting pregnancy
centers on fire they also will not vote
to condemn or criminalize killing a
newborn infant who has survived an
abortion
now part of their argument against
this act is that they say it's not
necessary because this isn't happening
right there's there's no abortionist who
would ever kill a newborn baby it's just
not happening
but that is pure gaslighting abortion
clinic Representatives themselves when
given the opportunity have not ruled out
infanticide
let us not forget
uh the case of Alyssa lapult snow
Planned Parenthood lobbyist testified in
front of a Florida House of
Representative subcommittee in 2013.
maybe you saw this video uh back when
this first happened but let's refresh
our memories
here's how she responded again she's a
representative for the abortion industry
and when she was asked what what happens
when a baby is born alive what will the
abortionist do
um here's how she responded
for me to even ask you this question
because I'm almost in disbelief if a
baby is born on a table as a result of a
botched abortion what would what would
Planned Parenthood want to have happen
to that child that's struggling for life
you're recognized thank you Mr chairman
um well you know we believe
we believe that
it's made should be left up to the fam
to the woman or family and the physician
um chair Davis and then we'll come back
to you Ripple leaving
thank you Mr chairman and I believe
you're in the uh committee room whenever
I asked representative Pigman the
question about
um what happens in a situation where a
baby is alive breathing on a table
moving
um what do your Physicians do at that
point
they're recognized
I
abortion provider
um so I do not have that information
oh go ahead sir
I understand that you're not a physician
but you do represent
Physicians who do perform this activity
in your temp can you tell me what
happens when a baby is alive on the
table
at that point what did they do with the
baby that is struggling to live you're
recognized I don't know and as it's been
reference earlier you know we don't know
even how prevalent this situation is
that goes on for another five minutes
now if babies are born alive and they're
provided care
she would simply say so it'd be a very
easy answer she would say well of course
we provide care to a child in that
circumstance
but she would not say so because it is
not so of course it isn't so of course
the abortion clinics would prefer to
kill the infant or let him die uh they
obviously have no moral compunction
about murdering babies and they realize
it'd be very bad for business to be
delivering life-saving care to a child
in the middle of a clinic dedicated to
killing them
they certainly don't want any ambulance
uh pulling up outside with paramedics
rushing in and taking a barely breathing
infant to the hospital they don't want
that such a scene would cause you know
for one thing the other women in the
waiting room to ask lots of questions
that the clinic doesn't want to answer
it is also a recognition like
trying to save a baby's life rushing him
to the hospital that is a recognition of
the humanity of the baby and they don't
want to recognize that
their whole business rests on not
recognizing that
so it's easier to solve the problem
another way and that's exactly what they
do
and it's what the Democrats want them to
continue doing
there was a series of democrat lawmakers
who stood up on the house floor to
register their shock and dismay over
this bill they were not only opposed to
giving Medical Care to dying infants but
they were outraged and offended at the
very suggestion of such a thing
Democratic representative Suzanne
bonamici denounced the legislation by
saying that it's extreme and dangerous
woman from Oregon is recognized for one
minute thank you madam speaker this bill
is extremist dangerous and unnecessary
extremists because it would criminalize
doctors with up to five years in prison
and put them in fear of providing
life-saving medically necessary
procedures to those who are pregnant
dangerous because the bill has no
exceptions to protect the health of the
patient and no exception for cases where
there is a serious fetal anomaly and
unnecessary because as Mr Nadler said
it's already a crime to kill a baby born
alive
well I agree with her to a certain
extent we should not criminalize doctors
who kill infants or let them die from
neglect by giving them five years in
prison we should not do that
um that actually that's outrageous
we should criminalize them by giving
them the death penalty that's what we
should do
as for the rest we see again what
Democrats mean when they call something
extreme extreme extreme is basic moral
decency and common sense that's extreme
treating human life like it has meaning
rather than treating it like garbage to
be tossed in the trash is Extreme
oh that's extreme say the Democrats
representative Nadler had an even more
interesting take on this bill and a more
uh fascinating objection here's what he
said
the problem with this bill
is not
that it makes anything
that it is not that it provides any new
protection for infants the problem with
this bill is that it endangers some
infants by stating that that infant must
immediately be brought to the hospital
where depending on the circumstances
that may be the right thing to do for
the health and survival of that infant
or it may not
that is the problem with this bill it it
um directs and and mandates a certain
medical care which may not be
appropriate which may be in danger the
life of an infant in certain
circumstances that's why we oppose this
bill
did you get that it might endanger a
child's life to bring him to a hospital
now if Nadler was actually concerned
that the legislation doesn't do enough
to protect children he could have
proposed an amendment making it even
more Bulletproof
change it to say something along the
lines of uh the child must be offered
whatever Medical Care is most likely to
preserve his life or you know worse that
effect if those if that language isn't
already in the bill
that'd be a simple way to allay his
alleged concerns but the Democrats
weren't interested in adding language
like that to the bill they didn't want
the bill at all and the reason is clear
they do not wish to acknowledge the
humanity of The Unborn Child
they are the Democrats are in a very
literal sense anti-human anti-life
anti-child
and they prove it more and more every
day
now let's get to our headlines
well you know how I feel about New
Year's resolutions you set out with
lofty goals you stick to them for two
weeks then you fall right back into your
old habits well lucky for you I have a
goal that you can accomplish today
complete your will with epic will just
119 and you can do it in as little as
five minutes epic will can help you
create your last will and testament your
living will and even Healthcare power of
attorney their step-by-step online form
makes it incredibly easy all you got to
do is fill in the blanks fifty percent
of Americans don't have a will choose
today to be in that smarter half go to
epicwell.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 off uh on uh epic Will's
complete will package that again is
epicwill.com promo code Walsh
okay lots of cover in the headlines
um and I suppose we'll start with this
with a controversy in San Francisco
here's the ABC headline Art Gallery
owner who hosed down homeless woman in
San Francisco finds it quote hard to
apologize
the art gallery owner is seen in a now
viral video spraying water from a hose
onto an unhoused woman remember not
homeless unhoused
what's the difference between homeless
and unhoused nothing at all there is no
difference those are like synonyms it's
just that unhoused sounds more clunky
and uh yeah that's the politically
correct term now for that it's
distinction without a difference but
we've just decided like it's it's it's
time to update that language arbitrarily
and uh and so this is the new thing
um closing down and uh a an unhoused
woman is stopping short of apologizing
and is defending his actions Edson
Garcia the co-owner of uh brosh Cafe
recorded the cell phone video while he
was on his way to delivering a catering
order just after 6 a.m on Monday
he said incredulously I turned to the
side and saw the guy pouring water on
the lady Garcia who's seen the unhoused
woman in the north beach neighborhood
before sometimes asks her not to block
the doorway to his Cafe and has never
found her to be belligerent he adds that
given the weather conditions the man's
actions appeared especially cruel
it was cold and raining she was
screaming okay I'll move I'll move
it's not fair to see people doing stuff
like that
although interestingly enough if you've
seen this video and I've seen it I don't
it I don't recall in the video this
Garcia character actually likes stepping
in or saying anything and said he just
stands at a distance and Records it ABC
7 News anchor um Dion Lim Tracked Down
the man with the host Art Gallery owner
Collier Guin who admitted to his actions
quote I totally understand what an awful
thing that is to do but I also
understand what an awful thing it is to
leave her on the streets Gwynn says
there were repeated attempts to help the
woman over the past couple weeks and
that other nearby business owners have
complained about her presence blocking
the sidewalks and entryways he says the
police reports don't seem to help we
called the police there must be at least
25 calls to the police it's two days in
a homeless shelter two days in jail and
then they drop them right back out on
the street
Monday the when Gwen says she refused to
move and resisted his help in moving her
belongings down the street he sprayed
her down as a last resort this woman is
a very very sad situation she's very
psychotic all right so there's again
this video and it's been making the
rounds online and uh people are very
upset and saying what a horrible man
this is now
I'm not saying that he responded the
right way here but or he did what I
would have done in that situation but I
am saying that
as a society we have shown
I think a lot of sympathy to the
homeless to drug addicts to criminals
um I think that again as a society we
sympathize more with with people like
that than any other Society ever has
like we it'd be hard to sympathize more
um it would be hard to be more lenient
it would be hard to be more like
uh
welcoming and and
um and all of that
and enabling than we already are so
there's a lot of sympathy
but my point is what about sympathy with
an understanding for law-abiding
citizens who are trying to live their
lives and trying to run their businesses
and are simply Fed Up and desperate and
they don't know what to do how about
Sympathy For That
okay what about what about sympathizing
with that if you if you are capable of
sympathizing with some strung out drug
addict on a street corner or a criminal
who's like you know victimizing those
same law-abiding citizens if you're able
if you're able to find sympathy for
those people can you not sympathize with
just normal human beings who manage to
follow the law be productive Citizens
Care for their families they're trying
to contribute to their community
and yet they find themselves stymied
every step of the way
by these people in their communities who
are not contributing and who instead are
making themselves into a strain and a
drain
is there any sympathy for that
because for me you know that's where my
sympathy goes first my sympathy first
goes to the law-abiding people that just
normal people are trying to live their
lives and be productive that's why I
sympathize with first
and that's the first thing I thought
when I saw this video I think I think a
lot of people they see that first thing
they think is oh that poor woman first
thing I think is like this guy's been
driven to the brink and he's trying to
run a business and he's got and he's got
homeless drug addicts just setting up
encampments right outside his business
and he's not the only one he's business
owners all over these communities in
nearly every city dealing with this
they're they're just trying to live
their lives and provide a good or a
service to to people in their
neighborhoods
and they look outside and they've got
just uh homeless drug addict refugee
camps on the sidewalk
and nothing they do like what else can
they do I think that's what they're
saying that's what this guy's saying
he's like
what am I supposed to do about this I
called the police I take her to the
shelter I offer to help and nothing
matters it always ends up back here what
am I supposed to do
and business owners who are having their
livelihood stolen from them taken from
them
because their their communities are
being overrun and you know people don't
even want to walk down the street
anymore like no one's going to go to the
business because they don't want to have
to walk by the homeless drug addicts
laying on the sidewalk and they don't
have to walk their children by that
and so these businesses are going under
what do you want them to do just accept
it and say well that's how it is I guess
my life is destroyed
so people are desperate and when people
get desperate they do things that
might make you queasy and uncomfortable
and that's what happens
but I blame the the people in power who
are responsible for causing this state
of desperation that's who I blame
so all of the all these people who are
who just instinctively look for excuses
for the societal parasites and the
leeches and the the criminals and all
that the dregs of society everyone
instinctively looks for every excuse for
those people can you take a little bit
of that Grace what I'm saying is take a
little sliver of that Grace
that you will give to someone who has
decided to live there and you know it
just live their entire life dedicated to
their favorite drug
and so that you can't even help them
because no matter whatever help you give
them or money you give them they'll
spend it on the drug take a sliver of
the grace that you show to that person
who contributes absolutely nothing to
your community and only helps to destroy
it a little sliver of that grid not even
just like a little bit of a little
portion of the grace and sympathy and
give it to everybody else who's affected
by this
that's what I'm asking for
and I don't know anything else about
this guy maybe it'll turn out that he's
a serial killer he's a psych he's psycho
himself maybe there's all kinds of
details about him and he's just the
worst guy in the world I don't know I
don't know anything about him
um
all I know is
what we see in the video and it is
possible it is very possible
to imagine a scenario where someone is
just driven to the brink and they don't
know what to do anymore
update on a big story yesterday
Associated Press
computer breakdown sews chaos across the
US Air travel system thousands of
flights across the U.S were canceled or
delayed Wednesday after a system that
offers safety information to Pilots
failed and the government launched an
investigation to the breakdown which
grounded some planes for hours
Federal Aviation Administration said
preliminary indications trace the outage
to a damaged database file the agency
said it would take steps to avoid
another similar disruption
so there was a damaged database file and
that's what caused the disruption and uh
Pete bootage you know he was doing
interviews yesterday
[Applause]
um he's had quite a tenure
there was the rail worker strike
recently which happened as Buddha judge
went on vacation there's the truck
driver uh shortage of course the supply
chain crisis that happened right as he
was going on maternity leave and it also
didn't make him you know he wasn't going
to cut his maternity leave short because
of that
and now
every flight grounded for the first time
since 9 11.
but don't worry he's still doing a great
job
at least this is what we've been told by
his Defenders on social media and in the
corporate media uh all you do is look at
his resume he's obviously doing a great
job the leftist group vote vets tweeted
this and this has kind of been the
talking point about
secretary budajig is a Rhodes scholar
Harvard at Oxford Alum and served in
Afghanistan for the U.S Navy as an
intelligence officer if anyone is up for
the task it's him he's by far
extraordinarily qualified for his job we
can't say that for everyone in
Washington
now I think this is a great tweet and I
love it because um
because it is the best argument and it's
very succinct but it is the best
argument against credentialism
that I've ever read
because that's what this is this is
credentialism
yes he hasn't done anything he hasn't
demonstrated any aptitude at all in his
job there is no evidence
that he has been successful or that he's
even slightly competent
now yeah you can you BL can you blame
him 100
for everything that happens in the world
of Transportation when when he's the
transportation secretary obviously not
okay he's not personally sitting there
checking all the computer systems at the
FAA every day
but the Bucks got to stop somewhere and
he is the transportation secretary
and he's getting paid accordingly he's
getting paid quite handsomely he's
taking uh he had you know I think 18
private jet trips in 2022 so he's flying
private jets all over the world and all
of that and so that means the buck stops
with you and um you can you can try to
mitigate
his culpability here to whatever extent
you want to if you're desperate to find
excuses
but the point is that there's lots of
evidence that he's very bad at his job
there is no evidence that he's good at
it
and they try to bail him out by pointing
to all of his credentials and all the
you know all the the classes that he
took and the degrees that he has and
look at all these impressive
institutions that are on his resume
yeah and none of that means anything
doesn't mean anything you you can be a
road scholar you could go to Harvard and
Oxford and I mean you could you could
you could get a PhD at every Ivy League
school in the world if you want to and
that will not even come close to proving
or demonstrating that you have any
skills or any actual aptitude in any
area at all
because an ability to read about
something
write papers regurgitate information
also the ability to pay for all this
schooling if you're even paying for it
um
you can have that ability
and yet that's really your only ability
there are very many people who are who
are very educated
uh in a in a in an official kind of
sense
but then it turns out that's their only
skill their only skill is in that it's
like being a state of us they have a
certain skill at being a student and so
they can thrive in that particular
environment when they're sitting in a
class and they're listening to lectures
and they're repeating information and
then they're writing papers like that is
uh that's a certain skill it is
but it doesn't necessarily translate any
other anywhere else in life
people to judge probably the prime
example of that
next we got this representative Byron
Donalds uh has been under intense
criticism from the left and because you
know he's he deserves it right because
he's uh committed the sin of being black
and Republican and so that's just no
good he appeared on Joy Reed's show and
uh left this on on social media you know
they said that
that the whole interview was just a
Smackdown she owned him she destroyed
him she tore him apart and this part in
particular has them cheering let's watch
it
my friend Jody Arrington who's going to
chair budget he wants to look into the
budget and also look into entitlements
do you know that Social Security is
going to be insolvent in 2018
but it's actually not true Financial
Community that's actually not true
that's actually not those are the facts
that's not should we not that if not
what the Republican party and with the
Tea Party have proposed is private
privatizing Social Security which would
actually subject Social Security to the
whims of the market which I don't think
that's not what they paid no if you look
at the returns
2006. the returns of the S P 500 since
2006. you're saying okay so you support
privatizing Social Security I want to
explain to you I am a financial
professional I'm Securities license
actually I just lost my licenses because
I'm not allowed to trade anymore because
I'm a member of Congress but let me
assure you if you look at the S P 500
from 2006 until today the growth rate in
the S P 500 it would have more than
taken care of Social Security way more
than the federal government and each
time that we had a crash it would
subject people's Social Security
so let me just hold on a second we're
not going to have a whole long thing on
Social Security but let me just be clear
you and you are in favor of privatizing
Social Security no I'm not in favor you
just argued for it I said you you just
started and I brought you the facts
if a bill came forward to privatize
Social Security before no because what
we should be doing okay
you just explained that the s p would be
a better return better return so then
you are foreign
that's what counts as winning an
argument on the left
not true that's not true that's not true
that's all she did the whole time this
is this is uh uh cable news like that's
I don't know who won the argument there
um I'll tell you that cable news did not
win the argument that's a good argument
for like getting rid of cable news it's
just that that's that's everything wrong
with cable news right there and um by
the way do you know from that I'm
actually interested to know I'd like to
know how would uh Byron Donald's vote if
there was uh you know a bill to quote
unquote privatize Social Security she he
said no but let you know let me let me
tell you what I would do and she
wouldn't let him finish it but I'd like
to know I'd actually I'm interested to
know what is what his take is on that
so asking questions that you will not
allow the other person to to answer
is uh is that's MSNBC that's that's
cable news in general
and shouting not true not true
it's I mean it literally it's how my
kids argue with each other it's that's
that's what cover your ears not true I'm
not listening that is how nine-year-olds
argue
and even for them it's uh if they act
that way I say you're nine years old
you're too old to be acting that way
this is something as a parent happens
quite often I am constantly telling my
kids whether the nine-year-olds or the
six-year-old that you are too old to be
acting a certain way
but it's a way that these adults act all
the time
once again Society not doing parents a
lot of favors you know because I tell my
kids Ed you shouldn't act that way you
should act this way you should be more
mature and they can look out once they
once they're able to really be exposed
to the culture they'll see that what do
you mean these adults are way older than
me they act like this all the time
like you said I was too old for this Dad
uh he is right about social security by
the way and and um what will really make
it insolvent or what will really bring
the system down is that eventually there
won't be enough workers to support it
you know the people that are uh
Defenders of Social Security will say
that well it's not going to be insolvent
it's not going into insolvency that's
all a false narrative that's not true
because
um you know it's it's not as though uh
people paid in Social Security and then
the money that they paid in went
somewhere and it's been it's being
stored somewhere and now the government
is is robbing that storage box and we're
going to run out of money
right
um the government is robbing Social
Security but that's but that's a but
it's the the point is that it's
constantly being funded by the current
crop of workers
that's what they say as a way of
Defending it but it's like Well it can't
be it's all well yeah but the problem is
that eventually
as our as our as our country becomes
more and more top-heavy generationally
people are having fewer and fewer
children they're just one and there are
fewer and fewer people even getting jobs
in the first place people dropping out
of the workforce
we're gonna get to a point
where there's just not enough workers
around to support it
in order to keep or or in order to
support it the taxes would have to be so
high
while on the other end what you're
getting out of it if you're on Social
Security is so low that it's not worth
it anymore
that is where we're heading it's just uh
whether it's going to be in 20 years or
30 years or 50 years it it's just it is
a it's a it's a matter of demographics
it's a matter of you just just look at
the replacement rate
um the population replacement rate
that's that's how we know
that it's not in the long term it's not
sustainable
it's just it's simply a question of
at what point
do we have to conf do we officially have
to confront the reality this doesn't
work anymore
you keep putting it off but putting it
off and putting it off because no
politician wants to deal with this
because it's very unpopular it's
unpopular on both sides
and also older people they vote you know
they vote much more than younger people
do and
so if you say anything about social
security other than let's keep doing it
exactly like we're doing it now if you
say anything outside of that you're
going to pay the price politically which
is why all these cowards most of them
anyway
won't won't address it
um
personally I'm in favor of privatizing
and although I don't really like the
phrase privatize
that's that's not how I would put it
you know privatize makes it sound it's
just it makes some more complicated than
it actually is
and for me it's very simple like I want
to be in charge of my own retirement
okay
thank you government for
uh offering to take care of that for me
but no thank you I don't want it I just
don't want you to do that I don't I want
to opt out of that system I don't want
to be a part of it I want to keep my
money and let me worry about it
I'm even well I'll sign some sort of
contract if you want
where I am pledging
that I will take care of my retirement
and if I don't do it if things go wrong
if I if I say that I mean I don't I I'm
not allowed to get any government
assistance when I'm older give me that
contract and I will sign it right now
and uh and I will live and die by that
so that's what I mean by privatizing it
and also by the way my concern about
social security here's my concern about
I think a lot of people missed the uh
missed the point
my concern is less about the fact that
eventually it won't be there anymore
that's part of the problem
but my bigger concern is right now
um it's that younger people and young
families they need that money now they
can't afford this
six percent of your paycheck that's
substantial especially over the course
of a year
you just can't afford it
you got young families
who already can barely afford to go out
and you know buy a carton of eggs and
some milk
they can't afford to have this massive
amount take it out of their check every
year to keep this system afloat they
just can't afford it they need that
money it's their money and they need it
that's that's my concern
so I'm not even
worried about 40 years from now I mean I
am worried about that we should be
worried about it more but there's also
the issue of right now that somehow gets
lost in this conversation entirely that
you've got young families who are like
they they're just starting out their
lives
their their economic Financial stability
is very important
arguably it's the most important that's
the group who are the most it's it's the
most important for them to be stable
and for them to be solvent
and they cannot afford it
all right
I want to play a quick this Quick Clip
it's rather disturbing but
uh
Prince Harry so he's got his Memoir out
and we talked about Prince Harry a
little bit just to start the week
um and we mentioned how he very much
wants his privacy or claims that he does
and yet he's he he did three quote
unquote major interviews just this week
he's all over the place now he's got
this Memoir out
and even though he's someone who claims
he wants privacy in his Memoir he's not
only airing Dirty Laundry about his
family but he goes into
uh very intimate detail about himself
and and providing information that
nobody asked for
and so I said that there was there's one
part apparently in the Memoir where he
talks about frostbite
um that he suffered on his genitalia
which is already too much information
already TMI
but then this was making the rounds of
social media yesterday there's here's
the audiobook clip of that little
Passage
and it's
way more disturbing than I even
anticipated
um
listen
my penis was oscillating between
extremely sensitive and borderline
traumatized
the last place I wanted to be was Frost
necklace stand
I've been trying some home remedies
including one recommended by a friend
she urged me to apply Elizabeth Arden
cream
my mom used that on her lips you want me
to put that on my todger It Works Harry
trust me
I found a tube and the minute I opened
it the smell transported me through time
I thought as if my mother was right
there in the room
and I took a smidge and applied it down
there
uh
um
so
so I was reminding you of your
I don't know we don't want to break that
down I don't want to break that down
anymore than what we already heard there
and except to say that
yeah it's just like it it's an
interesting clip because it starts
it starts disturbing okay we're
beginning at the at the beginning of
this little 30 second clip we hear about
his his penis being traumatized
um which is already too much but then
like as it continues it's just layers
and layers it's this it's this it's like
the a very creepy onion and as you peel
back the layers it just gets worse and
worse and by the end you're you're left
with many more questions
then you have answers and they're
questions that you never really wanted
to ask to begin with
except to say you know maybe the
ultimate answer here is that this is
actually very disturbed this is like a
disturbed person uh Prince Harry is and
I also don't I don't understand why we
still call him Prince Harry maybe
because nobody know what's his last name
so we just just saying Harry sounds
weird so that's the reason he still has
the prince thing going on
but it is a very disturbed person and uh
he's somebody with
mommy issues and uh and daddy issues and
all kinds of issues
it might also explain
how we ended up with
Meghan Markle in the first place
we talked about this on Monday I said
that Meghan Markle is like the perfect
she's really the perfect model
for men to look at uh so that they can
like look at her and everything about
her and the way that she is and
especially the way that she uh conducts
herself in a marriage as a wife and then
look at that and then find the opposite
of that just find the opposite of
everything about her and you'll be doing
okay because all the red flags are there
one of the major red flags for me for uh
Meghan Markle is that she has no respect
for for Harry's family she hates his
family has no respect
there's another viral clip and I was
looking for it I couldn't find it I
didn't spend that much time looking for
it but there's another clip that was in
there in their Netflix mini series that
uh that came out as part of their quest
for privacy and that came out back in
December
and there's a Now sort of Infamous clip
where she is
um making fun of uh uh Queen Elizabeth
and making fun of like making a joke
about the first time that she met Queen
Elizabeth and just just like in this
very mocking kind of eye rolling way and
meanwhile Prince Harry is sitting there
and you could tell he's not comfortable
with having his family made fun of this
way especially in public on camera but
he's just sitting there like a you know
a little tame puppy dog
and so I said
one of the red flags you're looking for
as a man when you're trying to find a
wife
is uh if you find a woman and she
doesn't respect your family she hates
your family she wants to isolate you
from your family and from your friends
and people closest to you that's a red
flag uh the question for for Harry is
like did she did he not know this about
her and more and more I'm starting to
think well he did know this about her
and that's one of the reasons that he
married her
for him the red flag was What attracted
him
because of all his family issues and the
fact that that she resents his family is
part of the reason he married her it was
meant to be you know uh a finger in the
eye of of his family and all the rest of
it
that's the psychoanalysis but I'll
leave most of that for someone else
um
all right
we don't have a lot of time so I gotta
choose
this is from the mount Miami Herald
headline she was catching a flight in
Florida then TSA noticed her emotional
support snake
snake on a plane almost this isn't the
plot of a sequel to the action flick
last month a woman traveling through
Tampa International Airport attempted to
Stow her boa constrictor in her carry-on
luggage it was a boa constrictor
um
according to Transportation Security
Administration a TSA tweet shows the
X-ray of the four foot creature that
passed through the screening machine
passengers uh must navigate before
getting to the gate the reptile is lit
up in Orange coiled up in a figure eight
nearby are images of a laptop and two
pairs of shoes the agency said that
after the snake was discovered the pet
owner was called out of the line
she reportedly told guards that the boa
constrictor named Bartholomew
was her emotional support pet
the post reports our officers at Tampa
International didn't find this
hysterical
well it's not a bad book you know not a
bad pun and also not a bad name for a
boa constrictor if you're going to have
a boa constrictor pet which I don't
recommend uh Bartholomew not a bad name
now here's here's what I'll say you know
I'm actually okay I'm actually okay with
this
um
if we're going to do the the emotional
support animal thing at all
and if you're allowed to bring your dog
on a plane
then I don't see any reason why you
can't bring the snake too we okay the
the special status and privilege we give
to dogs doesn't make any sense to me and
uh so if we're gonna do that like if I
have to sit next to your dog on a plane
okay if you're if the plane can turn
into a kennel then why can't it turn
into a you know reptile house
because I don't see any like you might
see a difference you might say well a
dog's totally different I don't see it
to me animal is an animal and I don't
want to fly with an animal so for
allowing that then yeah bring the snake
on too
now you know we make exceptions now
they're so so dogs are capable of
actually providing a real service to
human beings so a seeing eye dog or
something like that then that that's
different
but anything where it's emotional
support it just makes me feel good to
have this animal around
if you can do that with a uh with a dog
then why not with an animal so if
anything we should have more of this
just like make the the plane into a
full-on petting zoo bring your goats on
chickens whatever bring a cow on board
maybe say hey they run out of
if they're not doing a beverage service
then you've got a cow there you can
prefer milk and whatever
keep doing it until everyone's had
enough of it and then we can all go back
to a civilized society where we do not
allow animals at all on the plane
unless you put them in the cargo hold or
something like that don't bring them up
with everybody else
all right
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
with everything going on in the world
right now you could really use a good
night's sleep that's why you need to
check out Helix mattress I've had my
Helix for years now and I absolutely
love it I sleep like a baby
that's about to change when we have
babies but uh still when I get a chance
to sleep it's great with this mattress a
mattress should never be a one size
fits-all solution because why should you
have to compromise on comfort you
shouldn't Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you because why would you buy a mattress
made for somebody else go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their
two-minute sleep quiz and find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free plus Helix has a 10
year warranty and you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will I guaranteed Helix has over
12 000 five-star reviews they're
financing options and flexible payment
plans make it so so easy for a great
night's sleep and it's just not that far
away all you got to do is call Helix
Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is an amazing offer
take advantage of it at helixsleep.com
Walsh with Helix better sleep starts now
Evan says only Matt can describe Bronies
with that level of dry disdain
how else would I describe them is there
any other way to describe Bronies then
well I guess you could have enthusiastic
disdain or you know more sort of
colorful disdain
so yeah so my disdain is of a more dry
uh
flavor but
the stain is no matter what kind of
disdain it is it ought to be disdain
when you're talking about Bronies
um
Sam says Matt pitbulls kill a total of
30 people a year 30 mostly just they're
bad owners that is not nearly enough to
create the kind of panic you're engaging
in
okay so this was uh this is a an
interesting conversation as we uh and
and you know I think enough has been
said about pit bulls apparently I I
didn't even realize this but the you
know we've been talking about pit bulls
a little bit and I mentioned it on
Twitter and so this is It's become a big
thing on Twitter now it's been trending
all week I guess it's a conversation
about pit bulls and um
probably enough has been said about it
but
there's this exact argument that that I
I've heard from from multiple people
that well you know there are X number of
pit bulls in the in the country you know
millions or whatever and and only 30
people a year are killed by them and so
it's just look at the percentages it's
point zero whatever percent and it's
just not enough to justify
well it does it does
raise the question of like well how many
people need to be horrifically mauled to
death by Pitbulls before you would admit
that it's a problem
um
but so I'm thinking about this and so
here's here's my here's the way that I
would I think about this because that's
always an interesting question anytime
you're talking about the threat that
something poses or you know a danger in
a certain area of life and you're trying
to figure out is this a reasonable
danger or not it's that's always kind of
a question how do you you know if x
number of people are killed by y
activity well is that too many or is it
not that many or what if it is like it
where's the line where do you draw it
I think part of the problem is that
people are very often when they're
asking this question about something
they're making apples and oranges
comparison you know taking this one
thing and comparing it to something
totally outside of its own category in
order to make the argument that this
thing is safe or it's dangerous either
way what you have to do is compare
things within their categories
right
so the question is not
how many people are killed by pit bulls
and by the way it's not just killed like
there's the number killed and this
person says 30. some people on Twitter
were telling me it's 20 a year I think
last year it was close to 50 that were
killed let's just say 30 though let's
just say 30. let's just go with that 30
a year okay the conservative estimate
um
so 30 are killed by Pitbulls and you
could say well
uh look at the look at the number of
people killed in car accidents this is
this is just astronomically more and you
don't want to ban all the cars do you
well that's that's different though also
because you know if you get rid of cars
for example you have completely upended
Society like with modern civilization
can't function without the automobile so
if all automobiles disappeared overnight
society would come crashing down if all
pitbulls disappear the same thing is not
going to happen but the real problem is
that it's some that is something outside
of its category it's not a relevant
comparison
so what you have to look at is
how dangerous are pit bulls not compared
to automobiles or lightning strikes how
dangerous are they compared to other
domesticated dogs and that's how you can
judge whether this poses an unreasonable
Danger
and when you make that Apples to Apples
comparison you find that the danger is
by is certainly overwhelmingly
unreasonable
because pitbulls kill say 30 a year all
other dogs combined all other dog breeds
combined kill far less than that so they
are responsible for a vastly
disproportionate number of not only
fatal mullings and fatal attacks but
also attacks that lead to
hospitalizations they are responsible
for almost all of them
while all other dog breeds combine for
almost none of them
and so that's the point
it's not how much more dangerous is a
pit bull than some other thing that is
not a dog but how much more dangerous is
it than every other dog
and when you find when you when you find
something that's an outlier like this
that tells you that there is something
seriously catastrophically wrong
um the uh the
analogy that I that I made yesterday is
just to put this in perspective imagine
for a moment that
Burger King this is not the case but
just hypothetically what if Burger King
was responsible for giving 30 people a
year fatal food poisoning and then
hundreds more it put in the hospital
with food poisoning it's a 30 a year
hundreds more every year are food poison
are given you know fatal or very serious
food poisoning from Burger King
and um what have you looked and you saw
that that every other fast food
restaurant combines for kill you know to
to account for almost no other fatal
food poisoning so almost all of the
Fatal food poisonings that happen in the
country are from Burger King
specifically
and that they account for a vastly
vastly disproportionate number of fatal
food poisonings
and it's so it's 30 people every year
year after year after year after year
are killed by food poisoning from Burger
King
now here's the question
would you still eat at Burger King
yeah Burger King might still be in that
case safer than like skydiving or bungee
jumping or it might even be safer than
driving down the road but when compared
to every other fast food option
of course you're not going to eat at the
place that kills 30 people a year
so there's a there is a chance at with
with Burger King whereas the chance with
every other fast food place of dying for
food poisoning is almost zero
so I think that's the kind of apples to
apples comparison and that's how you can
tell that there's something seriously
Ashley says my son just said Matt is
canceled because Dad Cooks scrambled
eggs on our electric stove all the time
I guess you have to have more talent for
that Matt life is rough as a as a popper
well
listen
uh you can do it okay there's lots of
things that can be done but the question
is can it be done well
and scrambled eggs brings up a whole
other conversation we don't have time
for but uh I take scrambled eggs very
very seriously and what I found is that
most people when they think of scrambled
eggs they just break some eggs into a
bowl they mix it around they dump it in
and then they just you know they
scramble it and that's it
okay the fluffiness is not there it's
not cooked the right way it doesn't have
the flavor it's supposed to have it
doesn't have the right there's supposed
to be a kind of fluffy and creamy
texture to it and that's not there
and so what that tells me is that your
husband just doesn't take a scrambled
egg seriously enough that's
you know it's a new year but leftist
companies are still up to their same old
dirty tricks ladies it's time to help
your guys wash out the woke once and for
all with Jeremy's Razor's new line of
men's Staples he'll love the tea tree
and argon oil infused shampoo and
conditioner exfoliating charcoal body
wash or if he's a soap traditionalist
who prefers something to hold on to he's
got the oatmeal and citrus soap scrub
they smell great and they're all made
right here in the USA by a Men's
Grooming company that doesn't hate men
shop the new Jeremy's hair face and body
wash collection and kick woke out of his
bathroom and when you visit the store do
it through my URL so I get the referral
bragging rights as well uh you got to go
to dailywire.com Walsh treat your man to
some great Jeremy's Razor's products
today that's dailywire.com Walsh now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
the Golden Globes happened two nights
ago and I'm telling you this because the
chances are you didn't already know I
only knew because part of my job is to
scour the internet for all the news of
the day including the most obscure bits
of news like the Golden Globe Awards
awards and if the ratings are in any
indication it would seem that most
people were unaware or aware and totally
uninterested in the Golden Globes
um now they didn't air last year at all
because the people who run the show had
to take a year off to confront their
racism or whatever but this year's show
was down 20 compared to 2021's broadcast
and that show in 21 was down
exponentially compared to the year
before so nobody cares about this stuff
anymore and fewer and fewer people care
every year
I'm not here to tell you that you should
care I'm only here to cancel someone
because that's the segment and today it
must be the host of the Golden Globes
for 2023. Gerard Carmichael Carmichael
is an alleged comedian best known for
coming out of the closet during one of
his Netflix specials the Golden Globes
needed to find someone who checked
multiple diversity boxes and as a gay
black man Carmichael fit the bill but is
he actually a good comedian or a skilled
show host
well that consideration was not
important and it became very obvious
that it wasn't important very quickly
during Carmichael's opening monologue
which you can see part of here
I'm here because I'm black
[Applause]
I'll catch everyone in the room up
settle down a little bit I'll tell you
what's been going on
this show
the Golden Globe awards did not air last
year
because
the Hollywood Foreign Press Association
which I I won't say they were a racist
organization
but
they didn't have a single black member
until George Floyd died
so do with that information what you
will
why am I here on the stage with you guys
tonight well I was at home
foreign
tea
and I got a phone call from my man
Stephen Hill
Stephen Hill's a great producer and he
said Gerard
really I'm honored to be making this
phone call he said uh I'm producing the
80th Golden Globes and
it would be an honor
if you would agree to join as the host
I was like whoa
you know
like one minute you're making mint tea
at home
the next you're invited to be the black
face up in in battle white organization
hilarious stuff all the jokes and this
goes on for another six minutes as
Carmichael recounts the story of how the
fascinating story of how he was offered
the job because he's a brilliant
comedian but he knew it was really
because of his race
um and then uh and he told the guy that
it's because of my race and the guy is
like no you're great
and uh told him he was really great and
and then he called his friend and he
asked her friend about it and she told
him to take the job because he's making
a lot of money for it
and and so ultimately that's what he
decided to do though he wants the Golden
Globes to know that this does not
absolve them of their racism and that
was the whole monologue that was it the
audience members laughing uncomfortably
the whole time terrified that the
cameras would show them reacting in a
way that Twitter deems inappropriate
that's that's the only funny thing about
the monologue potentially is nothing to
do with what he's saying but it's just
because people in the audience are like
I don't know
because they know that at any moment
that the camera could show them and and
so they're listening to a gay black man
and they're not sure is he trying to be
funny am I supposed to laugh at this am
I or if I laugh am I am I in trouble I
don't know what to do am I supposed to
be crying am I what am I supposed to do
here
so what are the problems well first of
all
um comedians are supposed to be funny
and uh you know I know this is a
controversial statement these days and
certainly becomes a great shock to most
modern comedians but comedians are
supposed to be funny that's the whole
job it's Rod Carmichael isn't funny
so he doesn't seem to have understood
the assignment now you might object to
my comedians are supposed to do comedy
Theory by saying that well sometimes a
comedian might want to make a more
serious or insightful point they don't
all they don't all have to be Mitch
Hedberg up there delivering a bunch of
uh one-liners and non-sequiturs this is
true though we could only wish that most
modern comedians were as good as Mitch
Hedberg but the point is that a comedian
is supposed to make those serious and
insightful points while also being funny
that's difficult to do but those in the
profession of being funny are supposed
to be able to do that
because that's their profession
I mean literally anyone can stand up on
stage and ramble
it takes skill to not only make an
insightful point but to do it while
being funny yet that's the skill that
comedians by definition are supposed to
have
it doesn't make any sense for a comedian
to not even try to be funny it's like
going to see a juggling act instead of
juggling the juggler stands in front of
you and delivers an economics lecture
now even if the lecture is good it's got
nothing to do with juggling now
if you talk about economics while
juggling that might be interesting that
would take some actual talent
but we see this sort of thing all over
society and not just with comedians
there's a severe lack of talent
particularly in the Arts so we lack
talented comedians artists painters
musicians poets filmmakers these are the
people who who don't actually
have the talents necessary to perform
their craft at a high level so they
compensate by pretending that they're
being bad on purpose
that's like our whole culture now is
just is is you're bad at it but you're
pretending it's on purpose
we've made bad into its own style its
own genre
so that we can all pretend that the
artist is engaging in some kind of bold
deconstruction of the art form instead
of facing the fact that he just simply
sucks at his job
second Carmichael allowed himself to be
the token black guy the diversity hire
he thinks he can get around this or
negate it by acknowledging it up front
he thinks that you know that makes the
whole performance meta and subversive
when in reality he's just a sellout with
an imaginate without an imagination
this is another thing we see all the
time now in art especially anything
involving Hollywood
is constantly making bad films that uh
that and there are films that
acknowledge their own Badness and that
acknowledgment is supposed to in itself
transform the Badness into something
good
superhero movies are the worst offenders
of this sort of thing these films they
they wink at the audience constantly
admitting to the corny and cliched
nature of the whole thing while
continuing along doing the corny and
cliched thing
now this might have been funny the first
time it was done 20 years ago but 100
movies and a thousand weeks later is
just a crutch used by lazy boring
writers in fact it's gotten so bad now
that the finale of the She-Hulk series
um the the season finale which of course
I didn't watch but from what I read
it actually had the character She-Hulk
walk through the screen and confront the
writers of her own show to complain
about the bad writing
now this was supposed to be subversive
once again it's self-aware and funny but
instead it was just a direct admission
by the writers that they are not good at
their jobs
it's not just superhero movies in Glass
Onion the sequel to Knives Out the
detective solves the murder discovering
that it was the most obvious culprit all
along like it's the guy that was obvious
it was obviously that guy the whole
movie and then in the end they said yep
it was that guy right you had its fall
from the beginning
and then he repeatedly acknowledges the
detective does in the film that the
murderer is stupid and obvious and lazy
which is just another way of
acknowledging that the writer of the
film is himself stupid obvious and lazy
these people have so thoroughly run out
of things to say that now they're
actually talking about how they have
nothing to say
third most importantly
even if we can forgive Carmichael for
being an unfunny sellout and we're
willing to sit back and listen to his
lecture we'll discover that what he's
saying about race is not the slightest
bit Brave or bold or risky that's how it
was so that's how the media reacted to
it
they said it was blistering because it
was a blistering monologue and there
were people on social media say it was
it was brilliant it was Brave it was
courageous
well it can never be brave for a liberal
black person to confront a bunch of
white people about their racism there is
no version of a white people or racist
speech delivered by a black person that
can ever be brave in our culture
the reason it cannot be brave is that it
has been done a million times already
and every time it's done it is
guaranteed to be applauded by all of the
most powerful people in the country
including and especially the ones you're
calling racist
you cannot be brave if you're saying
something that every Hollywood executive
and Fortune 500 CEO and politician would
publicly agree with
even if what you're saying is right it
can't possibly be brave there's nothing
Brave about your willingness to be
applauded for being brave
now if Carmichael wanted to actually be
brave and subversive and transgressive
he would have stood in front of that
audience and would have told them that
as a black man he is not oppressed in
America that um anti-black systemic
racism is imaginary and that white guilt
is a disease infecting a large portion
of the population including everyone
sitting in that room
now that would have been a bold
statement on a stage like that
it would have also easily been you know
much funnier
or you know what
maybe strike that because even more
subversive
and certainly uh more funny
would be to say nothing at all about
race okay the truly bold move would be
for the first black person
and and not only that but a black gay
person
to host the Golden Globes and then give
a monologue that isn't about being the
first black person to hold the host the
Golden Globes
okay in that environment in that
atmosphere for that guy to stand up
there and give a monologue that that
where he's telling jokes
that aren't about the fact that he's
black
now that would be a curveball
that's something that nobody would see
coming
but instead he went the safe route and
the unfunny route and that ultimately is
why he is today canceled
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you can become a member today and
you use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow or rather talk to you next week
but we have two more kids
um Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]